manuel valls on va faire un petit
questionnaire je vous propose de nous
des situations ou de choses et vous me
dites ce que vous préférez emmanuel
macron françois hollande
aller manger françois hollande
non mais françois hollande part par
loyauté parce que j'ai essayé saint
françois hollande par ailleurs je me
mets parce que j'ai été son premier
ministre et son ministre et donc par par
par loyauté wii est parce qu assez bien
avec ce qu'on a connu ensemble quoi
qu'il arrive on est plein de désaccord
avec françois hollande on n'a pas la
même vision des choses encore
aujourd'hui mais ce qu'on a connu le
terrorisme notamment nous allier à tout
jamais avec avec bernard cazeneuve
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
moments de tension extrême et françois
hollande de moments d'engueulade entre
vous pas du tout non parce que c'est
c'est difficile avec lui parce que
souvent avec un bon mot une blague
quelque chose il peut retourner la
situation j'ai eu au moment où il a
décidé de ne pas être candidat et
surtout quelques semaines avant avec la
publication d'un livre qu'il a beaucoup
alimenté de deux journalistes du monde
là je me suis vraiment fâché avec son
entourage a expliqué que cherchait une
excuse non je suis fâché avec lui parce
que je trouvais que c'était pas bien
pour à présent la public une fois que
vous avez quitté matignon est ce que
vous aviez des nouvelles de lui ou plus
du tout j'en ai eu régulièrement où il
aimerait maintenant vous en avez
régulière oui absolument on a toujours
là un peu plus d'an avec eux je reviens
là dessus mais avec sur certains
événements autour du procès on a été
amené à parler ensemble mais on garde un
lien et on dit qu'il est très sympa
françois basset vraiment s'est alors lui
disiez tout à l'heure les politiques on
découvre après à lui non il ya quelque
chose d'assez étonnant parce que
l'humour qui est le sien le sérieux
aussi dans des décisions très graves qui
ont été prises de la garder et c'est ce
mélange d'humour et de sérieux c'était
une de ses qualités il faut reconnaître
qu'il a eu du mal à l'incarner auprès
des auprès des français ça c'est une
c'est une réalité jusqu'à ne pas pouvoir
seront aussi d'eric qu'il ne pouvait pas
se représenter et donc moi lors donc
françois hollande parlera par loyauté
entre font dans la vie ça va pas lui
plaire que vous dites
vous préférez hollande par loyauté c'est
à dire quoi que le reste vous plaisait
pas non non mais parce que parce que
j'ai voté pour emmanuel macron parce
qu'il est le président actuel le
j'aurais pu aussi choisi un manuel
macron mais je fais le choix non parce
qu'on a partagé cinq ans de pouvoir et
avant une campagne électorale et avant
un compagnonnage au sein du au sein du
ps mais je pense que la loyauté
vis-à-vis d'un ancien président a pu
blic au-delà des désaccords c'est
quelque chose qui reste j'étais son
premier ministre son ministre voilà il
ad'ailleurs ou l'oublient souvent aidé
toute une génération à prendre des
responsabilités et une partie de cette
génération ne lui a pas été très
reconnaissant la télé ou la politique by
pr répondu c'est la politique
c'est non mais c'est la politique mais
alors la télé que les politiques
critiquent patati patata et quand même
le moyen le plus extraordinaire sous
toutes ses formes 2 un privilège voit la
première fois je sais pas que j'ai fait
et jt comme on dit à 20h à l'époque
c'était encore plus à la pression quand
on est quand on est premier ministre
faire des deux grosses émissions oui bah
oui mais roule non mais c'est il compris
quand on parle tout le temps ou de
l'image en permanence même une réponse à
l'assemblée nationale ça compte mais
quel privilège
quelle chance et quelles responsabilités
encore ce soir n'était pas une manière
de pouvoir parler à des millions de
personnes donc cesser non il faut il
faut bien l'utiliser moi j'aime bien
c'est un outil un instrument moyenne
communication qui est extraordinaire
après la télé peut rendre fou y compris
les politiques faites pas trop triste
que messier quitté barcelone pour venir
à non pas du tout parce que mais s'il me
suis ça ne s'est pas
fait
moi tu là
voici la trique je partais s'est dit
mais bon il connaît
c'était pour le barcelonais que je suis
pour le pour le supporter du du du barça
avec en plus deux clubs ont des comptes
quand ils jouent les uns contre les
autres mais barcelone et paris saint
germain ça a été un déchirement surtout
dans les conditions très triste très
très très minable du club à son égard
donc mais mais mais j'irai voir le match
dans quelques jours à l'écouté qui dira
où olivier verront
franchement olivier ferrand parce que
parce qu'une question de temps de
sérieuses et je vais vous dire j'ai vu
ça depuis l'espagne honnêtement en
espagne a beaucoup de défauts mais ce
débat totalement dingue
même s'il ya des vraies questions qui se
posent jamais elle se posait à l'époque
mais sur un professeur qui avait un
magnifique carrière et qui est quelqu'un
qui a une très grande réputation mais ce
ce débat autour de ce bruit donc
incompréhensible joyal yahia c'est ça
prend des proportions mais c'est celle à
100 a ajouté rooney de la jalousie aussi
il ya eu un peu de tout ça sans doute
dans le dol ce qui est il trop exposés
c'est vrai que c'était devenu une
vraiment
ce qui est inquiétant cyril en france et
que les seconds les élites ou ceux qui
gouvernent c'est vrai pour les
politiques seraient pour les
journalistes vrai pour les juges
c'est vrai aujourd'hui pour le corps
scientifique après après beaucoup
d'hésitations et beaucoup d'avis
contradictoires sur quelque chose que
personne ne connaissait je parlais de
lakovic 19 tout ça provoque des débats
et nuit à la confiance que les français
attendent c'est pour ça gagner pour y
aller compte il a été attaqué parce
qu'il saurait marseillais etc ou par
jalousie que vous venez vous avez senti
vous manuel valls que vous aviez
beaucoup beaucoup d'amis quand vous
étiez pro ministre est un petit peu
moins quand vous n'étiez plus nous parce
que mes vrais potes ouais mais vrai
copain mes amis et j'en ai heureusement
beaucoup depuis toujours depuis le lycée
depuis la fac c'est ces dernières années
il s'appelle stéphane il s'appelle alain
il s'appelle vincent que les horizons
pas
non mais c'est laid c'est des copains
mois beaucoup ne sont pas dans la
politique et c'est mes amis quoi qu'il
arrive ils invitent ya matinée oui bien
sûr mais quand on il était cantonné plus
à matignon ce qui m'a vite chez eux j'ai
quand même c'est quand même et on dresse
est devenu premier mois on reste amis on
reste amis pour la vie et ça c'est ses
amis là ils sont indestructibles et
c'est ça qui est le plus important quand
vous dit un politique des amis
politiques c'est pas vrai j'ai très peu
d'amis très peu de deux copains de potes
d'amis dans la politique avec qui je
pars en vacances j'en ai très peu parce
que cc c'est difficile comme un
politique a du mal à voir vraiment il y
en a pourtant mais des amis journalistes
parce que si un jour que ce journaliste
une info ou quelque chose il fait pas
son métier ou alors il brise une amitié
donc c'est un dilemme très très
compliqué mais l'amitié c'est ce qui m'a
aidé à tenir après mon après cette
période très c'est vous qui avez une
période difficile oui voila je pas par
rapport à ce que vient sur un coup franc
c'est ça n'est pas très grave mais j'ai
senti que le sol se dérobait sur mes
pieds que je vais partir voilà c'était
une manière aussi de de reconstruire ma
vie c'est pour ça que fut bien vous êtes
très bien là raymond kelly sa première
fois envoyé un premier ministre à west
ham en
réponse à ta c'est la masse et la
première fois et j'en profite comme il
est là quand il y avait eu les émeutes
qui m'ont beaucoup marqué - 2005 il
était déjà maire d'evry avait son copain
france par son copain c'est l'opposé
jean françois copé qui était maire de
meaux et evry et meaux avait été bien
tenu à l'époque et j'avais dit y a il
cessa pas bougé à evry parce que moi
j'étais déjà à l'époque dans les
quartiers jeunesse a pas bougé à evry ça
bouge à aulnay savez bouger partout evry
et moss avait pas bougé pour ça moi ya
pas de problème après moi je me dis
enfin son nom en direct pour le reste
partir en espagne revenir je trouve ça
un peu bizarre là de dire monsieur
raoult c'est un druide est
d'accord mais je dis je dis ce que je
pense c'est pas un druide est un c'est
quelqu'un de très sérieux
demandé de parler de chopard en tout cas
en tout cas précis où il à lui jamais
mon titre voilà un jeu différent il a
dit il a menti sur les routes mais après
je suis content de moi même vous le
demandez lui et je vais demander à
monsieur val soit là je suis content
d'avoir un premier ministre dans ma vie
si on m'avait dit que je parlais à un
premier ministre bis est impossible
comment à quel moment je vais m'adresser
un prémice
possible et je vous tire mon chapeau
pour les émeutes qui avaient en 2005
cochez vrille a été tenue bien les leur
dire que ma foi ça
je préfère rien dire
le druide c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelait
ces personnes c'est les sommités
mondiales a dit des choses très
différentes le gouvernement comme
d'autres gouvernements en europe ou dans
le monde sur cette question là se sont
trompés ou on est parfois m'ont menti on
fait des erreurs versé 7 c'est cette
réalité sur un sujet d'une complexité je
veux pas mettre à la place de ceux qui
ont gouverné sort était sûr été une
galère pour vous d'être là c'était dur
quand j'étais je confie né en espagne et
que je voyais ce qui se passait je
bouillais parce que c'était partagé
franchement c'est très difficile janet
la planète avait connu comme ça en
assurant nous confinement face à une
main à une maladie à une à cette
pandémie qui se répandait partout jamais
on a connu on a tous les êtres de la
planète ont pratiquement tous connu la
même la même réaction mais de l'autre
côté j'avais envie d'agir et c'est
peut-être là que j'ai ressenti le plus
de besoins de france se met aller-retour
jeu parfois un homme politique un homme
tout simplement un être humain il a pris
tellement de coups kiki qui cherchent là
où il est donc ils assurent fêlures il
ya une cassure au regard des benjamins
compte pour mais c'est vrai bonne chance
a écrit la tuerie caudalie cantilène
cassure malheur à gaza dit pas s'ils
voyagent pas de change de femme
[Applaudissements]
ça mais c'est mais je pense que cette
fois-ci nouvelle ère fois en ce moment
oui merci c'était le point
[Rires]
et leeds et mourront marine le pen
pourquoi la vache folle à la cdc du rab
à l'arrivée c'est une vraie galère ses
jokers
vous êtes obligé imaginons un deuxième
tour eric simon marina silva je veux pas
non parce qu'en plus c'est ça qui fait
le buzz et c'est ça ouais c'est ça bien
sûr il est en train de provoquer un
séisme - dans le camp le pen oui ça
c'est vrai vous pensez vraiment qu'ils
font c'est qu'ils peuvent terminer
devant et le premier tour je pense que
tout est possible et des gt j'ai discuté
avec des amis tout à l'heure et ils sont
persuadés que eric zemmour va assécher
marine le pen s'il sait s'ils se
présentent et qui va faire plus qu'elle
est que la halle à 18 dans les derniers
sondages lui à 11 et ils sont persuadés
parce qu'en fait ils disent que marine
le pen ce n'est plus le vote de
contestation aujourd'hui c'est voilà
eric zemmour et c'est long c'est lent
c'est un long processus
on verra tout peut se passer mais elle
s'est banalisé elle est apparue comme
incompétente ou au moins au moment du
fameux débat entre les deux cours avec
emmanuel macron les régionales ont été
très mauvaises et comme elle s'est
banalisé dans le camp on va dire
identitaire dans ce camp de la droite
extrême eric zemmour apparaît comme la
nouveauté je vais rajouter un élément
c'est pas forcément un compliment
voisins c'est comme une partie de cet
électorat envie d'être fiers d'une
culture d'une histoire même s'il a tort
même si ce qui dit parfois est horrible
sur pékin à théo de gaulle sur les
gamins juifs qui aurait pas dû être
enterré en israël etc c'est sa dernière
sortie mais il apparaît qu'il rend fier
cet électorat oui ce que je veux dire à
travers cette émission est l'histoire de
la culture et ses succès ce qui n'est
plus le cas de demain il ressemble
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière il est
presque plus les héritiers du père oui
le père que de la fille du coup
était possible tout les gens
ce qui ressort c'est qu'aujourd'hui
marine le pen est les limites elle est
trop policé c'est à dire qu'elle a
tellement vous ne voudrez plus que s'en
réjouir on peut dire ça voilà l'extrême
droite en france et de nous l'un des
plus plus modérée on devrait les
guillemets l'actuel voulu montrer que le
rassemblement national est un parti
comme les autres si aujourd'hui
justement c'est un parti comme les
autres et c'est ça qui je pense que si
les entrées se passer c'est que la
droite extrême où l'extrême droite
simplement comme on fait national
populisme c'est c'est cette droite-là
qui au fond porte vision qui n'est
évidemment pas la mienne qui divise
beaucoup le pays de bailleurs jean luc
mélenchon qui veut beaucoup de choses
nous oppose à des des choses plutôt
juste et hier soir dans une petite vidéo
qu'il a il a atterri hier mais est qui
et qui chauffait déjà cette émission et
d'eau et d'autres des bailleurs mais
mais c'est vrai que c'est la
confrontation d'une certaine vision là
delà de la france mais quelle plus à
droite aujourd'hui pour vous marine le
pen ou eric zemmour a je pense que sur
le plan idéologique ce plan des idées ce
plan la culture politique c'est
incontestablement et réserver un quota
non parce qu'il est dans un courant je
veux faire ça vend un peu mais d un
vieux courant qui hélas de charles
maurras cps de droite d'extrême droite
français de l'entre-deux-guerres des
références à pétain il n'est pas
républicain au sens historique du terme
donc je pense beaucoup plus à droite il
vous fait peur et peut gagner
vous savez dans dans le monde politique
d'aujourd'hui tout est possible
j'imagine qu'au etats unis beaucoup de
gens ont dit 30 ne peut pas gagner
comment alors c'est sûr modèle un
exemple un cas d'issue serait ce que est
ce que c'est parce que l'europe france
alors il ya une différence et gagne 2
tours vrai que est évidemment le
deuxième taux est un moyen de ceux de se
rattraper mais il peut surtout faire
abaisser le seuil de qualification au
deuxième tour si le pen s'écroule que
lui monte et que la droite républicaine
par exemple un candidat qui a qui
arrivent à faire un score qui aurait 14
15 mai voire plus multiples niveaux peut
être qualifier au deuxième tour avec 16
à 17% si ça avait été un genre marin
jean marie delambre le voilà avec 16% à
peine un peu plus que 5 mois en 2002
donc ça peut ça peut tout changer et
emmanuel macron peut se retrouver sur
s'ils résistent je crois que ça devrait
être le cas face à xavier bertrand ou
actionner pécresse voit eric zemmour
tout est possible et attention avec un
pays qui a
abstention massive aux régionales oui on
a dit c'est pas grave si c'est très
grave docteur et deuxièmement avec les
gilets jaunes et avec une contestation
civique ya quand même beau les gens sont
très fâchés sur 13 en colère si on va
tuer attention sauf que pardon mais jean
michel aphatie l'autre jour a déclaré
c'est lequel il a dit on d'un peu à tous
les intellectuels et hommes politiques
qui ont été débattre face à zemmour qui
l'ont fait exister qui l'ont fait naître
à la télévision en allant dé battre un
peu comme ça face à un professeur et
vous avez fait partie de ces gens j'ai
vu d'ailleurs le débat qui a débattu a
salué ce que vous le regrettez non pas
du tout alors là je pense que alors ce
débat zemmour est fabriqué par la préf
passé des années ils journalistes
d'ailleurs mon figaro ensuite il a passé
des années à chercher chez ruquier on
n'est pas couché ensuite sur rtl les
grandes radios populaires bon donc non
et puis le succès de ces libres mais ça
c'était prévu on avait parlé tous les
deux mais le leur et adoubé des batwa
mais d'autres n'est alors l'idée au
débat on a eu ce débat avec le pen
alors aujourd'hui de ne pas débattre
dans la société d'aujourd'hui d'autant
plus qu'avec lui ça a été une heure où
il a parlé beaucoup d'histoires beaucoup
du passé peut-être trop mais moi je suis
allé avec avec mon expérience
les études d'histoire que j'ai fait mon
goût pour le passé mais aussi j'espère
pour futur de la france lui dire que sa
vision de l'histoire ne correspondait
pas à la mienne et à celle qu'il fallait
pour ce pays et pour et policières de de
lui-même d'eau il faut y aller pour
combative que sinon il est seul à
défendre ses idées donc mélenchon a
raison de débattre cette plus avec lui
tout ce que vous n'êtes plus mélenchon
anne hidalgo
avec mélenchon il ya il ya quand même
des fossés et ne devrait pas traiter de
nazi une fois ouais c'est vrai ça rend
pas quand même
ouais c'est très bien connu mélenchon au
plc bay hill et du talent bien
évidemment et je l'écouté puis
représente un courant politique dans ce
pays il a fait 17 ou 18 % aux dernières
présidentielles mais il ya trop de
choses qui nous sépare notamment sur la
vision de la de la france non il faut
cesser vrai qu'un fossé aussi entre anne
hidalgo et vous également mais il est
frais
c'est qu'elle a fait mais
vous allez l'invité ouais mais alors
elle va peut-être venir alors oui on
l'embrassé j'adore
regarder comment on va bien ensemble
regardez fera une belle maison sans avec
les entreprises de btp qu'elle connaît
alors bâtir un truc énorme non mais elle
est là une belle histoire personnelle
oui c'est vrai nom mais j'ai rien contre
avec justesse et chine
on est content parce que quand on envoie
turtur je peux vous dire venez à paris
un jour oui même à rêver non je les
rencontre à jouer très sympa et jaune et
d'un ba oui mais ça aussi il y passe ça
nous fait une belle jambe bah bien c'est
l'accusation spatule très bonne émission
alors là un peu plus compliqué et c'est
vrai que là je voulais en parler ce soir
avec vous manuel valls c8 ou arte c'est
sait plus ces mythes oui bah oui on
alors ça fait beaucoup de bruit ces
derniers jours alors que procès des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 s'est
ouvert un documentaire d'arte et vous
allez très très en colère dans les
ombres du bataclan on vous reprocher
d'avoir privilégié vos intérêts
électoraux cette nuit là en faisant
intervenir la berri on va regarder
l'extrait et c'est vrai que ça vous et
que ça vous a énormément touchés regarde
y avait non seulement leur aide quand
ils perdent à venir mais nous voir il y
avait également l'équipe du gène hla
qu'ils ont des célestins qui était
justement présent qui finissent à
l'entraînement de lutte antiterroriste
et qui était équipé est en mesure
d'intervenir rapidement
ces tunnels les personnes qui avaient
accès à l'information ce que c'était
bien avant de valls il plaque du préfet
ils l'ont déjà fait si qu'à ce moment là
on était dans un contexte particulier
nous avions manuel valls qui entend que
les ministres visés clairement le poste
de président la république alors ça
c'est que même si vous le découvrez
peut-être ce soir et c'est vrai que
je sais que ça vous a énormément touchés
c'est gravissime réalisation et c'est
des accusations très très monde qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ça vous savez
d'abord c'est il a été diffusé quelques
jours avant le début des procès et moi
je comprends parfaitement que les
parlementaires à travers les commissions
d'enquêté et la presse travers des
documentaires façon travail essaie de
comprendre nous processus qui a mené à
ces attentats les failles qui ont pu
exister à nos frontières en grèce où les
problèmes en belgique ou même chez nous
ce débat il est légitime et les français
le demandent et surtout les familles et
les victimes ils veulent comprendre
comme ça ça me paraît normal et que nous
nous répondions à ces questions c'est la
moindre des choses j'irai moi-même
d'ailleurs témoigné dans quelques mois à
ceux à ceux à ce procès mais alors faire
le procès de l'état est pas des
terroristes rentrer dans des thèses
complotistes est alors imaginer que le
soir des attentats dans le cas où nous
étions en train de connaître le stade de
france les terrasses les restaurants le
bataclan bien évidemment y aurait un
premier ministre qui serait en train
d'appeler lui-même les policiers en
disant non c'est c'est la berri qui
intervient et par le raid parce qu'il
privilégie les policiers exactement ça
c'est là c'est une diff alors la mairie
c'est la gendarmerie norel n'ont jamais
versé la police de la périphérie
le jdj
les gendarmes dont on disait à l'époque
il était proche mais lisez qu'en plus le
projet en question donnent directement
les ordres parce que ces mecs-là vont
l'aider pour la présidentielle non mais
il faut être assez dérangé mais parce
qu'on est en plein procès parce que je
pense aux victimes
parce que quand je vois ça moi j'ai
encore les la gorge kitty qui se nouent
essayer encore qu'on vous en parle gg
les gels et j'ai des amis des proches
qui ont perdu leurs gamin sur une des
terrasses et donc l'idée qu'on puisse
imaginer qu'à cause de moi
il puis c'est parce que c'est ça l'idée
c'est à cause de moi on a retardé
l'intervention il ya eu des morts
supplémentaires c'est insupportable on
peut tout accepter mais pas ça et c'est
pour ça que j'ai demandé à richard malka
qui monte qui monte conseil qui est mon
avocat dans cette affaire de porter
plainte contre x parce que je ne peux
pas accepter cela bernard cazeneuve
d'ailleurs a très bien répondu dans une
interview qui passaient après le
ministre le documentaire qui était un
excellent ministre de l'intérieur il l'a
fait aussi sur une autre chaîne après on
peut pas laisser parce que si on laisse
tout peut en plus c'est arte alors comme
ça ça c'est forcément le service n'est
pas libre non et c'est intolérable moi
je ça me donne envie de crier de chialer
parce que ça n'est pas acceptable qu'on
dise à coup pointe les problèmes qu'ils
aient eu pour être plus efficace ensuite
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme sage
le jeu le col je le comprends c'est ce
qui m'a opposé à d'autres responsables
politiques qui ont essayé d'utiliser les
attentats à des fins politiques non face
à à ces attentats il faut être digne
unis et là c'est une absence de dignité
et c'est dangereux même pour pour la
vérité de ce que jamais pour
m'interviewer dans ce mail important
même pas donné l'occasion de répondre à
ces accusations intime masqué voir tout
ça c'est dégueulasse